sadate en israël samedi son ministre des
affaires étrangères démissionne laos 300
une extradition discuter il est passible
d'une peine maximale de cinq ans de
prison
andré bergeron à l'elysée nous gagnerons
la cinquième semaine de congés congrès
les maires de france alain poher réélu
président le retour de brel un silence
tapageur là messieurs bonsoir c'est
officiel depuis trois heures maintenant
le président égyptien anouar el-sadate
se rendra en israël encore plus tôt
qu'on l'imaginé dès samedi soir des
apprennent il restera à jérusalem
jusqu'à lundi et prononcera un discours
à la knesset
dimanche après-midi en anglais en arabe
on ne sait trop pour l'instant pas plus
qu'on ne sait s'il visitera comme le
souhaite monsieur begin le mémorial à la
mémoire des juifs assassinés par les
neiges l'événement nous a paru si
important nous avons décidé de
retransmettre cette arrivée en direct
sur un thème 2 samedi à 18h30 même chose
dimanche pour le discours de la knesset
à dire de l'assemblée nationale
israélienne et une partie des journaux
du week-end sera diffusée en direct de
jérusalem mais dans cette attente rayon
égyptien rencontre déjà de très
sérieuses difficultés à l'intérieur même
de son gouvernement
puisque son ministre des affaires
étrangères ismaël phare mis à
démissionner et que son successeur
présumé marcuz ryad a fait la même chose
un poste accepter finalement par le
suspect a gagné dès l'entrée en fonction
du président carter monsieur famille
s'était rendu à washington en plein
accord avec sa date il était résolument
partisan d'une politique des trois de
coopération avec les états unis
ce qui n'empêchait pas d'évoquer
régulièrement les droits des
palestiniens et la nécessité de dégager
une solution au proche-orient en accord
avec yasser arafat
ismail famille diriger la diplomatie
égyptien depuis quatre ans
ok on répétait souvent à son sujet il
est plus adapté à sa date
manière de souligner contre le président
égyptien et son ministre
l'entente était absolument sans nuage
pourtant aujourd'hui ismail familles
préfèrent se retirer il n'est pas
d'accord avec la décision de sa date de
se rendre à jérusalem
en cela ils adoptent la même position
que le président syrien al-assad qui
estime que la visite à jérusalem n'a
abouti à aucun résultat positif pour la
syrie pour l'egypte et pour l'ensemble
du monde arabe
alors pourquoi ce voyage rapidement
jacques adoue charles parce qu'il ya les
recruter et bien y'a 10 en termes à
peine voilés c'est déjà un mauvais coup
porté monde arabe
or il y a le ce qu'on appelle le front
du refus c'est à dire l'irak qui n'est
pas d'accord qui parle de trahison
la libye qui parle de trahison et on
apprend ce soir que le fath les
palestiniens la principale organisation
palestinienne le fatah dit dans sa date
ne doit pas se rendre en jérusalem
de plus l'agent star déclare sadate
ignore les protestations du monde arabe
s'il accepte de francs dans le même
temps si vous voulez il ya un effet de
rouleau compresseur qui risque si ça
date attend trop de l'écraser très
rapidement et je pense que c'est une
une des raisons pour lesquelles il a
précipité le mouvement tactiquement
c'est très adroit mais c'est également
très dangereux parce que j'ai peur que
anouar sadate dans cette affaire prenne
un maximum de risques et seules puisque
vous l'avez dit son entourage commencent
à lâcher finalement c'est donc un
s'adaptent très isolé qui va se rendre à
jérusalem teckel chances de succès dans
sa mission
je ne sais pas s'il est isolé je ne sais
pas s'il sera isolé mais je pense que si
sa mission jérusalem échoue ce sera un
homme seul de toute manière devant
l'importance de l'événement israël a
d'ores et déjà demandé aux nations unies
l'ajournement du débat sur le proche
orient prévue la semaine prochaine
reste à savoir maintenant comment va se
dérouler le voyage menahem begin le
premier ministre israélien vient
d'essayer de monsieur begin vient
d'expliquer que 60 fonctionnaires
égyptiens avec à leur tête le chef de
cabinet du président sadate arriveront
demain en israël à bord d'un appareil
militaire égyptien par un vol direct
ils seront logés à l'hôtel king david à
jérusalem
et c'est là que va résider le président
sadate pendant les deux nuits de son
séjour
monsieur bedie n'a révélé que le
président sadate s'était renseigné
auprès des dirigeants israéliens sur
leur la plus propice d'arrivée pour ne
pas troubler le shabbat
le premier ministre israélien a demandé
au président sadate s'il voulait venir
au mémorial des martyrs juifs
après sa visite à la mosquée al aqsa
mais sa date on n'a pas encore répondu
pour le discours à la knesset si
monsieur sadate parle en arabe
je répondrai en hébreu s'il parle en
anglais je répondrai en anglais enfin
monsieur begin a formulé l'espoir d'être
invité un jour au caire je rappelle que
nous retransmettrons donc les moments
forts de ce voyage en direct sur un
thème de pendant le week-end par
l'entière vous regardiez le suppose très
beau france bulgarie sur un thème de une
voiture quitter la prison de la santé à
l'intérieur claude croissant là les
avocats de la bande à baader
la voiture se rendaient à strasbourg est
là un hélicoptère devait le conduire à
stuttgart dans l'ex prison de vad
un passage de frontière qui a un nom
l'extradition depuis début d'après midi
la chambre d'accusation de la cour
d'appel de paris en avait hier donner la
possibilité au gouvernement
français le fond rapide qu'elle soit
l'opération a suscité un gros volume de
commentaires nous revenons dans un
instant sur la polémique qui s'est
engagé en france met tout de suite les
réactions en allemagne en allemagne où
désormais maître croissant est passible
d'une peine maximum de cinq ans de
prison
inutile de vous dire que les milieux
officiels allemands n'ont pas caché leur
satisfaction
il se met dans la presse presstalis de
l'extradition de klose croissant est
accueillie comme une victoire
internationale dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme
et comme une défaite très sensible de
ceux qui à l'étranger notamment
sympathise avec le terrorisme allemand
côté gouvernemental une réaction plus
nuancé on se montre bien entendu
satisfait de l'évolution de cette
affaire croissant mais on cache cet atys
faction sous une réserve prudente
l'opinion est-allemand de se réjouit
quant à elle de savoir qu lance
croissant dans une prison allemande au
niveau de la classe politique
on sait cependant que la sphère
croissant est loin d'être terminée on
s'attend à des réactions anti allemande
à l'étranger notamment en italie et en
france
et l'on s'attend également à ce que
l'étranger observe avec une scrupuleuse
attention le sort que la justice
allemande réservera à l'avocat croissant
pour l'heure on reproche à claude
croissant d'avoir utilisé son cabinet
d'avocat comme une sorte de centrale
d'information et d'opérations également
pour les disciples de la bande à baader
du groupe baader-meinhof de plus il
apparaît troublant et pas seulement dans
les milieux policiers que 6 des
terroristes figurant sur les avis de
recherche est allé sur tous les murs
d'allemagne fédérale soit d'anciens
collaborateurs ou collaboratrice du
cabinet de m croissant le sort de claude
croissant dépend à présent des juges de
stuttgart
ces derniers savent parfaitement qu'au
terme des accords d'extradition
franco-allemand signés entre paris et
bonn
ils ne pourront cependant poursuivre
claude croissant que sous le seul chef
d'accusation retenu par les juges
français à savoir la mise en place et
l'entretien d'un système de
communication entre malfaiteurs
le dossier de claude croissant est donc
à présent
moins lourd qu'avant sa fuite à paris on
ne peut donc pas dire que son séjour
parisien lui et nuit et aggraver son cas
par rapport à la justice allemande
en revanche en france je vous le disais
les protestations d'affluer du côté des
partis de gauche et des organisations
d'avocats qui ont dénoncé je cite le
scandale de cette extradition
le syndicat de la magistrature lui a
parlé d'une décision de justice
contraire aux principes fondamentaux du
droit et je ne vous cite pas les
différentes communiqué qui nous sont pas
revus pour essayer de vous présenter de
façon complète les deux dossiers le
juridique et le politique
nous avons confié à deux nos
journalistes paul le faire et jean
françois kahn afin que votre information
soit parfaite d'abord le dossier
juridique
voilà je crois que vous pas oublier pour
des passionnés un peu le débat que la
décision d'extradition est une décision
politique qui ne relèvent pas des juges
les l'arrêt de la chambre d'accusation
et en une analyse juridique des textes
en présence les juges permettait cette
décision politique
absolument mais le gouvernement français
n'était pas lié par la décision des par
l'arrêt de la chambre d'accusation
bon faut bien se souvenir que les juges
avaient devant eux deux demandes
d'extradition il en a accepté une ils
ont refusé la seconde la seconde qui
était beaucoup plus lourd dans ses
conséquences que la première mais la
seconde maison dit c'est une c'est une
demande qui avait un aspect politique et
surtout surtout les juges ont dit il n'y
a pas dans le dossier allemand
suffisamment de preuves en revanche ils
ont considéré que pour ce qui concerne
la première demande d'extradition
celle qui pour lesquels chronos pas sans
risque cinq ans de prison pour cette
demande de premières demandes
d'extradition les juges français ont
estimé qu'il y avait suffisamment de
preuves dans le dossier présenté par les
allemands pour dire oui en effet claude
poissant a outrepassé ses droits de
défenseur il l'est relève de droit
commun d'une dalle et du rock au minck
en france on en a marre général mais un
délit qui existent également dans le
total français à ce moment là on peut
dire oui à l'extradition
alors je pense qu'il faut également
souligner que les
magistrat français on avait pour réduire
le cas un texte qui était à leur
disposition mais qui est en même temps
les obliger un peu incertaine à une
certaine rigueur dans l'analyse et la
convention j'ai dit à franco allemande
qui a été qui a été fait par peut-être
plus part des politiques par les
juristes mais n'empêche que les
magistrats français avait un test qu'il
devait suivre et ne pouvaient pas
s'écarter je veux dire par là qu'un juge
français n'a pas à porter des jugements
de valeur sur certaines nouveautés tout
à fait légalement 9mm fédéral et des
lois qui en effet depuis cet été
restreignent les droits de la défense
c'est vrai mais les juges magistrats
français n'avait pas mais ça ne regarde
pas ce n'est pas leur problème
alors il reste maintenant à se dire
pourquoi le l'exposition s'est faite si
rapidement mais le gouvernement je parle
toujours au nouveau niveau juridique
nouveau gouvernement n'est pas lié par
un recours éventuel au conseil d'état
alors maintenant un autre niveau
jean-françois kahn le dos il y occupe
olitique en tout cas plus passionnel oui
d'ailleurs un peu le dossier de ceux qui
s'opposent à cette décision
je voulais les protestations viennent
vous l'avais dit en général des milieux
de gauche mais aussi des milieux
judiciaires
sir d'avocats de magistrats qui se ne
sont pas nécessairement de gauche
faut dire aussi que la plupart de ceux
qui s'opposent à sa décision affirme
qu'il rejette totalement le terrorise de
la bande à baader et qui ne partagent
pas nécessairement les idées de monsieur
croissant alors pourquoi s'oppose-t-il à
cette décision est bien le premier d'un
argument consiste à dire regardez ce qui
s'est passé pour abou daoud vous
souvenez ce terroriste palestinien qui
avait commis un certain nombre de crimes
qu'on avait arrêté en france l'allemagne
et israël demandé son extradition et là
au contraire on l'a libéré et spa on n'a
pas accepté l'extradition alors ils
disent
puisqu'on l'a libéré pourquoi parce
qu'il fallait faire plaisir à des états
arabes riches qui ont du pétrole est
aujourd'hui pourquoi est-ce qu'on
extrade croissant parce que nous avons
un puissant pays voisins l'allemagne
alors est ce que la raison d'état n'a
pas été plus forte que la justice voilà
s'il voulait un des arguments des
opposants dû verser leurs arguments
deuxième critique qu'ils font et disent
est ce qu'un pote quand même un risque
pour les exilés politiques en général
parce qu'enfin il ya en france des vous
savez des exilés politiques soviétique
par exemple les chiliens la plupart
in à méditer pour leurs idées ils ont
des liaisons avec les gens la barre
alors ils disent qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si demain c'est gouvernement
disait eh ben ils sont complices de
groupes terroristes qui agissent chez
nous d'autant plus quand il était nu
alors effectivement alors de l'autre
côté on répond à ces arguments ont dit
oui mais c'est pas la même chose parce
que le chili ait mis un seul ticket une
dictature alors que l'allemagne est une
démocratie on sait qu'il sera jugé tout
à fait légalement et enfin le dernier
argument peut-être le plus intéressantes
et celui là paul defaye vous l'a dit il
y avait là la demande d'extradition
était basé d'abord sur une accusation à
savoir que dix ans côte croissant était
complice des actions criminelles des
terroristes bien ça a été rejetée cela
par la chambre d'accusation
l'autre l'autre demande d'extradition
était basée sur le fait que l'on se
croise en avait fait la liaison entre
ses clients prison et l'extérieur ça
c'était accepté alors ils disent les
opposants en france j10 m'enfin est-ce
que depuis un siècle
tous les avocats ne font pas ça est ce
que les avocats du fln n'était pas pro
fln et faisait la liaison les avocats de
l'ouest promesses et faisait la liaison
comme l'avocat louis saez d'été
royalistes et faisait sans doute des
liaisons et donc est ce que ce n'est pas
une menace qui pèse sur tous les avocats
voilà je crois pour l'ensemble de ces
arguments puisque nous y sommes sachez
que cette nuit le sénat a profondément
remanié le projet de loi sur le secret
de l'instruction le texte du
gouvernement a été largement amputé
avant d'être adopté et puis justice
toujours avec l'ouverture aujourd'hui de
la première journée du deuxième procès
pailleron premier procès avait jugé les
deux jeunes garçons responsables de
l'incendié de ce c es il ya un peu plus
de cinq ans le deuxième juge maintenant
est responsable des fautes de
construction et des fautes
vous allez le voir dans ce document très
éloquent il y en a
pourquoi pourquoi ces enfants et quatre
adultes ont-ils brûlé en 48 minutes dans
cette école toute neuve deux anciens
élèves ont été condamné la semaine
dernière à 5 ans et 4 ans de prison avec
sursis pour avoir enflammé une corbeille
à papier imprégné d'alcool
il aura fallu cinquante sept modes
enquête pour comprendre pourquoi et
comment ce s à brûler complètement en
dépit de la lutte acharnée des pompiers
qui savaient qu'ils voyaient des
silhouettes d'enfants s'agiter derrière
les flammes
les enfants venus le soir apprendre la
musique le crs était composé de quatre
étages préfabriqué avec ossature
métallique sur un étage en béton les
enquêteurs furent tout de suite intrigué
par l'extrême rapidité du feu et la
naissance simultanée de plusieurs foyers
la réponse se trouvait en partie dans le
plan de la construction par exemple de
véritables cheminée latéral rejoints par
des vides horizontaux à chaque niveau
entre la plaque de béton supérieur et le
faux plafond inférieur à cela s'ajoute
et d'autres vide le long des façades qui
n'étant pas étanche favoriser des appels
d'air supplémentaire en somme le cs
pailleron était une sorte de gruyère à
l'intérieur duquel des courants d'air se
produisait sur toute la longueur et sur
toute la hauteur une véritable cheminée
à tirage multiples attisée par ses
courants d'air les flamands ont donc
ramper dans tous les sens ce qui
explique l'apparition d'un premier foyer
puis presque aussitôt d'un autre
à l'opposé du bâtiment une combustion
facilité en outre par la présence de
plaques non fixée de polystyrène expansé
matériaux qui se consument en dégageant
une épaisse fumée noire toxiques
puis on découvrira plus tard que
l'ensemble des gaines l'électricité
avaient été installées sans aucune
protection
et aussi que les portes qui devait être
théoriquement
coupe feu pour retenir les flammes
durant une heure étaient doublés
simplement de cartons les poutrelles
métalliques étaient aussi vulnérable en
effet le revêtement d'amiante s'arrêter
au niveau du faux plafond
c'est à dire aux parties visibles les
poutrelles était donc nue dans les vides
qui furent en réalité les couloirs de
propagation du feu c'est ce qui explique
que sous l'effet de la chaleur
ses poutrelles se soit tordu qu'elle ait
fondu en quelque sorte et que le crs à
20h18 48 minutes seulement après le
début de l'incendié se soit effondré
comme un château de cartes
plus tard on s'apercevra que la grande
conduite de gaz faute d'un système de
fermeture automatique n'avait cessé
d'alimenter le foyer comme une torchère
sur une pierre tombale
voilà ça c'était le l'emplacement du cs
pailleron aujourd'hui je crois que le
dossier est accablant
chaque branche et valéry giscard
d'estaing aujourd'hui demain les deux
chefs d'état seront forcément conduit à
évoquer les propositions du shah d'iran
à washington hier un blocage du prix du
pétrole pendant un an
un nouveau sondage fillon sofres
effritement de la gauche qui passe à 49
% stagnation de la majorité à 47 % le
reste 4 % allant aux écologistes
encore un pavé dans la mare de la
majorité lancés par jean-jacques sens
très bien
une investiture radical accordé à 120
candidats et puis cette condamnation
sans appel il faut changer la majorité
la politique et le gouvernement est un
plus andré bergeron à l'elysée ce matin
le leader de force ouvrière en est
ressorti avec la confirmation d'un
certain nombre d' assurances de la part
du gouvernement une augmentation
exceptionnelle du smic qui serait
étudiée au prochain conseil des
ministres est opérationnel dès le 1er
décembre relèvement à partir de cette
même date du minimum vieillesse à onze
mille francs et enfin revalorisation des
allocations familiales
voilà pour ce qu andré bergeron a pris
il lui est resté à revenir sur ce
thème favori depuis un mois la cinquième
semaine de congés payés
le président est d'accord pour qu'on
réduise la durée maximum du travail qui
est encore actuellement de 50 heures ce
qui est beaucoup trop et puis également
qu'on modifie la réglementation sur les
équivalences
c'est un problème qui peut paraître
secondaire mais qui est important
puisque on impose à certaines catégories
de salariés
une durée de présence supérieure à ce
qui leur est payé et la cinquième
semaine de congés payés alors la
cinquième semaine le président admet
qu'un problème existe et étant donné
qu'il y as divergences en ce qui
concerne le coût de cette mesure
il faut qu'on en discute et vous savez
que nous rencontrons les patrons le 5
décembre prochain et que c'est par
conséquent avec eux que nous allons
d'une manière concrète abordé la
question mais je reste tout à fait
confiant pour ce qui me concerne nous
allons gagner pour le deuxième mois
consécutif le commerce extérieur a été
excédentaire en octobre ça veut dire que
la france a vendu plus de produits à
l'étranger qu'elle n'en a acheté
du coup le déficit commercial n'est plus
que de 10 milliards et demi il avait été
de 20 milliards en tout 20 milliards et
demi même en 76 le commerce intérieur
maintenant légalement veut assainir le
marché de gros de rungis
une des principales étapes de la
distribution de produits alimentaires en
france
rungis vous savez c'est ce gigantesque
marché qui a remplacé les vieilles
halles de paris
et c'est là que les détaillants de la
région parisienne viennent chaque jour
s'approvisionner et il faut dire que ce
marché n'a jamais très bien fonctionné
ce tableau au coeur du marché de rungis
c'est un symbole normalement devrait
élire les quantités de fruits et de
légumes disponibles chaque jour
cela permettrait une information
complète des acheteurs et des vendeurs
en fait ce tableau il n'a jamais
fonctionné pour des raisons techniques
ou peut-être parce que personne ne le
souhaitais vraiment l'électronique n'a
pas remplacé la bicyclette et le bouche
à oreille pour faire circuler
l'information
c'est en tout cas un symbole pour ce
marché de rungis dont le fonctionnement
n'a jamais correspondu à son modernisme
pour le gouvernement c'est un facteur
d'inflation le fonctionnement de rungis
doit être améliorée le marché de gros de
rungis est un marché très important je
dirais énorme
il correspond à 2 millions de tonnes de
marchandises chaque année chaque jour
300 milles transactions sur ce marché
c'est aussi 12% de l'ensemble des fruits
et légumes du pays
c'est 70 % de l'alimentation de la
région parisienne
il est bien évident qu'un marché d'une
telle ampleur est difficile à gérer et
par conséquent coûteux et ses coûts se
répercute naturellement sur les prix
d'où la décision du gouvernement de
prendre un certain nombre de mesures
la première va consister à améliorer
l'information sur ce gigantesque marché
de reims améliorer ce qu'on appelle la
transparence du marché
par exemple faire fonctionner les
tableaux les circuits télévision
intérieur pour que chacun acheteurs et
vendeurs soit informé tout de suite les
quantités offertes et des prix pratiqués
pour les professionnels qui se sont
toujours accommodé d'un certain secret
ce n'est pas cela qui améliorera
beaucoup les choses avec une information
mieux fait en gagnant n'ont rien parce
que le marché ne se fait pas par des
tableaux et se fait pas par des
graphiques qui se fait par la discussion
permanente tous les jours entre vendeurs
et acheteurs alors content que à 9
heures du matin à 10 heures du matin
acheteurs connaissent le tonnage que lui
même a estimé à 10h15 ou à 10h30 en
définitive parce que ces professionnels
sont des professionnels comme je vous le
disais hé bien les courses qu'on se font
quand même très bien
en définitive il ya d'autres pratiques
semble-t-il à rungis par exemple on vit
que les grossistes se revendre entre
leurs cargaisons dans un magasin de gros
actuellement nous n'avons pas
le volume suffisant pour rendre à wagons
complets alors certains sont des
importateurs des supers grossistes et
revendre des quantités de gros si c'est
à dire une tonne de tonnes 3 tonnes
c'est à dire sept huit clients sur un
wagon de 20,22 euros 24 tonnes mais il
n'y a pas de transactions sur des
petites quantités nous n'avons pas des
marges pour nous permettre d'avoir des
transactions en chêne ça n'existe pas
c'est vrai les entreprises qui
travaillent à rungis ont souvent trop
petit trop dispersée sans doute parce
que rungis a été mal conçu et les
professionnels en sont conscients c'est
pourquoi ils sont favorables à la
deuxième mesure importante qui est la
restructuration physique de ce marché
notamment le groupement des entreprises
entre des mesures sans doute nécessaire
mais dont l'application sera longue et
les effets lointain ce n'est pas demain
qu'elles auront une influence sur
l'indicé n'y aura pas de prolongation de
grève pour les pilotes et les
mécaniciens d'air inter dont le
mouvement de revendication doit cesser
demain soir par ailleurs les hôtesses et
stewards d'air france ont annulé leur
mot d'ordre de grève dit on à la
direction d'air france
alain poher réélu facilement président
de l'association des maires de france
plus de 7000 voix contre un peu moins de
2700 au candidat socialiste est moins de
1000 pour représentants communistes à 6
h f le congrès de l'association des
maires de france et nous passons au foot
boureux figurez vous que j'ai dans les
mains je vais les avoir une véritable
relique que m'a confiée avec précaution
thierry roland c'est le maillot de
platini en fait c'est l'un des deux
maillots car il a donné l' aux moins
bien paraît-il un voire bulgare platini
qui nous aura bien fait plaisir hier
ainsi que tous ses camarades de l'équipe
de france en gagnant le billet pour
l'argentine et surtout en jouant bien on
les regarde jouer ça c'est le maillot de
platini donc
c'est sur l'un des nombreux corner
obtenu par l'équipe de france en
première mi temps que les tricolores
allaient marquer le premier but fraser
saute plus haut que tout le monde
dominique rocheteau réceptionne le
ballon et ouvre le score
on joue depuis trente-huit minutes c'est
le but qui soulage
en deuxième mi-temps les français
continuent à bien jouer six balles au
pied transmet à michel platini un
contrôle un coup de canon c'est le but
qui conscients
des tirs comme celui là on en voit
rarement avec un tel joueur
tout est possible
c'est enfin lacombe pour nous le
meilleur français qui donne à d'alger le
ballon du troisième but le bruit qu'ils
délivrent
16 novembre 1977 une soirée que michel
hidalgo entraîneur sélectionneur heureux
nous dira pas tous ceux qui aiment le
football en france non plus je suis le
tiercé le neuf le 11 et le 14 un peu
plus de 2000 francs pour 5 francs dans
l'ordre la princesse charlotte la mère
du prince rainier de monaco est décédé
hier soir
elle avait 79 la princesse anne elle a
déjà quitté l'hôpital on va vite en
grande bretagne mais son fils n'a
toujours pas de prénom puis je vous ai
gardé un cadeau pour la fin à partir de
demain
beaucoup d'entre vous poseront ce disque
sur leurs platines avec je crois une
certaine émotion
c'est le dernier brel jacques brel qui
sitôt l'enregistrement terminé à
regagner son petit paradis des îles
marquises le silence et les précautions
prises pour que rien ne perce jusqu'à ce
jour ont été jugés par certains non sans
raison comme une opération publicitaire
un million de disques seront mis en
place demain dans les magasins record
absolu pour un premier tirage faut dire
que le mystère brel celui de sa maladie
de sa vie nouvelle impressionne même ses
amis qu'il était pas fâché de le revoir
partiront
les pirogues sont viennent des mauvais
souvenirs au billet vert se connaît
mieux enfants
veux tu que je te dise j'ai mis nepad au
marquis ça m'a fait plaisir de voir
qu'il était enfin qui s'était bien tiré
le cette maladie il a une forme
éblouissante qui est plus jeune que
jamais il semble plus plus détaché
qu'avant bien qu'il n'y ait que douze
chansons en titre c'est très très varié
très très différents je pense que ce
serait plutôt le côté du plat pays les
chansons jerc j'ai retrouvé les textes
moi personnellement j'avais bien c'est
le genre regardez bien petit ces gens là
vraiment il n'a pas fait de concession
il a fait du très joli texte
il apporte et surtout une façon d' une
façon de se bagarrer contre des moulins
mais c'est lyon c'est pas pour rien
qu'il a fait lors de la manche après
c'est parce que wall est un véritable
don quichotte en réalité quand il a fait
quand il a fait l'homme de la manche
s'était lui même vent
oh
dry au volcan un pool10 tournoi
par mois
un voyage ibrahim s'y cacher et c'est
peut-être ce monde lui même des quarts
des cas des gens qui bougent les
immobiles vivent qu'ils fuient et ya pop
de potes fuite
c'est une envie de jouer envie d'aller y
lit la nuit partir parce qu'il se
sentait fatigué peut être était ce déjà
les signes annonciateurs du mal que je
crois qu'un certain moment il a été très
très mal
alors là c'est autre chose question de
chaleur il a peut-être choisi la vie
tout simplement
j'ai un rythme de vie où j'ai peut-être
plus très bien de temps vu mais j'ai
envie d'aller voir de sauvegarde et de
leur offrir le plan de nos terres
j'ai envie
ça
ça s'appelle la liberté et par manque de
bari le temps s'immobilise au marquis
c'est un esclavage savez la chanson
comme comme le métier d'amuseur c'est un
esclavage mais c'est un exploit a conçu
porte merveilleusement bien quand on
aime on a on a tous nos esclavage
il faut choisir ses esclavage et lui
l'avion choisir un autre car il a aussi
choisi un esclavage ils se dépensent
toujours bien sûr unix vous et là je
pense qu il a l'intention de faire du
parachutisme c'est ce qui m'a dit
l'autre va faire du parachute in parce
que dans l'état où il est c'est
impossible de faire du parachutisme
alors il va en faire ils veulent réussir
pour se prouver qu'il peut le faire
ils veulent chaque jour se trouver des
raisons de continuer la nuit soumis de
l'alizé ce pari
on marque qui eux pour un passage qu'il
est apparu que tant il aurait mis à
avoir un peu plus la paix seulement
comme lui demandait ça on a peut-être
exploiter ce silence qui demandait on en
a peut-être fait un peu près ce qu'une
publicité ça ça ne serait pas très
honnête ça n'est pas du tout ce qu'ils
souhaitaient je peux vous le garantir je
suis pas à vendre
comprenez
moi j'ai pas envie d'être avant vrai je
suis pas bon je pense que tout ce tapage
publicité athée parfaitement inutile
c'est une véritable opération d'intox
acceptable absolument pas d'accord ça
gêne les disquaires risque d'avoir de
l'embouteillage n'ont pas su pendant vos
voyages monde évitera du prel comme aux
débuts des petits pains précédent mais
vieillit
vieillir
silence tapageur au bout ou non le
disque est très beau ou laid coûterait
avant de passer à la météo très
rapidement noël mamère deux dernières
informations
oui nous apprenons que le brigadier
roger marche aux dons qui avait tué le
23 août dernier un jeune algérienne de
21 ans a été inculpé ce soir par le juge
d'instruction de nanterre d'homicide
volontaire et puis la visite du
président sadate en israël continue de
provoquer des remous dans le monde arabe
ainsi des appels à la grève générale ont
été lancées par la gauche libanaise pour
samedi jour donc de la visite du
président sadate en israël nous passons
donc à la météo pour terminer vous en
êtes rendu compte il a fait froid sur
l'ensemble du pays et les températures
étaient en baisse sauf dans les régions
méditerranéennes de mingue des nuages
nombreux des ardennes au jura et au nord
des alpes
accompagnant les pluies et les neiges
quelques éclaircies notamment au sud de
la bretagne
et puis sur la gironde des gelées
matinales apparaîtront dans l'intérieur
du pays
et je crois que c'est ainsi que se
termine cette riche actualité de ce 17
novembre
on retrouverait à 23h30 patrick lecocq
voulons toute l'équipe de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 qui m'a aidé à composer ce
journal je souhaite à tous une très très
bonne soirée